-We're about to play
a brand-new game.
It's time for "Make It Last."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Make It Last ♪
-But I'm going
to need some help.
He is the star of "Peacemaker,"
which premieres Thursday,
on HBO Max.
Please welcome John Cena!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh!
Whoa!
What?!
Oh, my gosh!
Wow!
Dude!
Oh, my God!
-Make some peace.
-Wow!
-Wow, wow.
Dude, I had no --
Five minutes ago,
you were not wearing this.
-No, I wasn't.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
That is what I'm talking about.
John Cena.
That's how you do it now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Peacemaker...
Peacemaker,
here's how this works.
There's gonna be
a number of challenges
that we'll have to do
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
It's so --
It's so cool to see this --
for as long as we can.
So we have to do it at the same
time for as long as we can.
Whoever stops
doing the challenge first
loses that round.
That --
-Challenge ourselves to last
as long as we can.
Reminds me of me as a teenager,
but let's go for it.
[ Laughter ]
You know what, though?
Before we do --
-Yeah.
-We played a lot of games.
When we played, what --
"Box of Lies"...
-Yeah.
-"Facebreaker."
-"Fish Slap" was a great one.
-"Fish Slap."
[ Laughter ]
-We always play these games,
and there's never really
anything at stake.
I want to -- I want to put
some stakes on the game tonight.
Do you guys want to see
something in the balance?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I'm feeling good, man.
I feel like a superhero.
So I'll tell you what.
You win, uh...
I'll give you my helmet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I will give you --
-For real?
You know
I will hold you to this.
-Yeah, that's why
I'm gonna kick your ass.
-Wow. Wow!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
-Yeah.
-Get it done.
-So -- So, okay.
-Well, what do I do?
-You win --
totally hypothetical situation.
Never gonna happen --
you get the helmet.
What happens if I win?
-I will give you
the "Tonight Show" microphone?
-Pfft!
[ Laughter ]
-I don't have --
I don't have a helmet.
-I want to put you
in an embarrassing situation.
Uh, let's see.
When I win, you shave your --
No, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I was gonna say shave your head.
But I have one better.
When I win, you frost your tips.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because -- Because you're gonna
frost your tips,
and people are gonna see you
with frosted tips,
and you're
gonna hate it so much,
then you're gonna
have to shave your head!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's a two-for-one
for Peacemaker.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ay-yi-yi-yi-yi-yi!
Uh, uh, okay.
Deal.
-Deal?
-Yeah. Deal.
Let's do this.
-You serious?
-Yeah.
-All right. We're in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's gonna be mine.
That's gonna be mine.
-Yeah.
You're gonna need it
'cause you're gonna be bald.
-If DC's watching -- yeah.
[ Laughs ]
All right, here we go.
For this first challenge,
we're gonna have to see who can
blow a ping pong ball in the air
for the longest.
-Okay, all right.
-Thank you.
-Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
Wow!
-I'm just gonna --
-Stud!
-I'm just gonna be at one
with my sensitivity,
and I'm just gonna
put this victory over here.
-Wow.
-Just gonna do that then.
Peacemaker, 1.
-I'm so nervous
about this frosted-tips thing.
-Fallon, none.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
All right, all right.
Here we go, 1-0.
For this one, it's a --
it's a balance challenge.
We have to balance
on these balance boards here
while holding trays of glasses
with one hand.
-What?
-Whoever can do it
the longest, wins.
Let me just see what the --
Can I just try to balance?
-Yeah, you and me both.
What the...?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have good --
-I'm a little lumbering.
Wait.
And, also, I'm nervous.
-This is hard enough.
Yeah, and we're
not even holding glass.
All right, here we go.
I'm gonna go on edge
and get my glass.
-Let's try it.
You ready?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Sad trombone ]
[ Bell dings ]
Didn't even the start the thing.
We didn't start the challenge.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't even start
the challenge at all,
and you are out.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm gonna --
Barely.
What the heck happened?
Well, I'm getting rid of --
I'm gonna drop this.
That was fantastic.
For this next challenge,
we're gonna have to see
who can hold the note
from Whitney Houston's
"I Will Always Love You"
the longest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Clears throat ]
♪ Hello ♪
Are you going low?
What are you gonna do?
-No, no, no,
I'm gonna go for it.
-All right.
-I'm already getting into --
on the level.
-Roots, whenever you're ready.
-1, 2, 3.
-♪ And I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I ♪
-♪ I-I-I-I-I ♪
-[ Straining ]
-♪ I-E-I-E-I! ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Are you kidding me?!
I thought I had that one!
[ Laughter ]
I thought I had that one.
-Peacemaker, 2.
Fallon, 1.
-Oh, my gosh.
You got pipes, bud.
-How many more
of these games you got?
[ Laughter ]
-For this next challenge --
Look at us.
We look like twins kind of.
[ Laughter ]
For this next challenge,
we have to see --
-What the [bleep]
are you looking at?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-For this next challenge,
we have to see who can hang on
to a fireman's pole the longest
without falling off.
-Okay. Well...
-Whoever does is the winner.
Have you ever --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got a little advantage
with the gloves.
-A superhero
is always ready for anything!
-Okay, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
All right, ready?
-I'll tell you what.
I'll spot you.
I'll beat you one-handed.
[ Audience groans ]
-Ready?
-Confidence is high.
I repeat --
confidence is high.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ready?
Set, go!
♪♪
-This was a mistake.
[ Grunts ]
Mother --
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow!
You did it one-handed.
We are down
to our final challenge.
Dude, is that a tie?
John, I'm gonna get this.
I'm gonna get --
I'm gonna get the helmet.
-You're gonna get a new haircut.
-I'm gonna get the helmet.
We're down to our
final challenge.
For this one,
it's too big for the studio.
-You do remember the last time
it came down to, like,
all the stakes
in the football game,
and you totally
just crapped the bed.
-Yeah.
No one remembers that.
-Where are we going?
-Follow me.
Come on, here we go.
-Oh, no, he doesn't remember.
-Come on, here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, this is --
All right, here we go.
We're gonna go into --
-Ed, nice to see you again.
-We're going into studio 6A.
Get ready for this.
-Oh, you son of a --
All right.
-Get ready, get ready.
-Fine, fine.
-That's right. Here we go.
-No problem.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
-All right.
-We have to see
who can last the longest
riding a mechanical bull.
That is your bull right there.
-Right here.
Now this one --
-Oh, yeah!
-This is --
This one is worth
1 million points,
so whoever wins this one,
wins it all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't care about the points.
You're gonna get a new haircut.
There's no way
you're getting this helmet.
-I didn't know
it was gonna get --
-All right, here we go.
-I didn't know I was
gonna get Peacemaker's helmet
tonight.
All right, here we go.
Are you ready for this?
-I'm ready.
Three -- one-handed.
Three, two, one, go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Bleep]
[ Bell dings ]
-It stopped?
Wait, wait!
I'm the winner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Peacemaker helmet is mine!
That's the deal!
You got that on tape?
I held on!
How much was the time?!
Yeah, hand over the helmet!
Let me --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You gotta give it to me.
Let me try it on.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You can see the inside, as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go back to my audience.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm keeping this.
I like this.
-Oh, man.
-I like this right here.
I'm --
Seriously, I'm -- I'm --
I am keeping this, buddy.
-James Gunn
is gonna be pissed.
-James Gunn is gonna be mad.
[ Laughs ]
John Cena, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-John, this is heavy,
this is expensive,
but I'm keeping this.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I'm a man of my word,
and, technically,
I don't own it, but it's yours.
[ Laughter ]
-So will I hear from lawyers?
-If you don't pick up the phone,
you won't.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-Are you gonna get in trouble
for doing this?
-Yes. Of course I am.
[ Laughter ]
I can't even go anywhere
with the costume.
They have, like, a person --
like, a person who travels
with the costume, and the helmet
comes in its own thing,
and the person
travels with the helmet.
They're like,
"Here's the costume,
and then here's the helmet.
Take care of it."
-I was gonna say --
I was gonna say to you --
I was gonna make fun of you and
go like, "Oh, do you have
a security guard?"
-No. You made fun of me enough.
-Thank you.
-Yeah.
I was gonna say, do you have
a security guard with you?
You're John Cena.
You are your own security guard.
-No, it's for the helmet.
It's for the helmet.
-It's for the helmet.
-That is now not mine
and wasn't mine in the first
place but now, somehow, you own.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's pretty cool.
I might just do it and just
host the show with it on.
-It's actually really cool,
because the audience
gets to see themselves on TV!
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to --
-That's not frosted tips,
but it'll do.
-[ Laughs ]
-We're kind of all winners here.
-That's the next bet.
We've never talked --
You've been on the show,
I want to say,
it's almost 15 times now.
We've known each other
a long time, yeah.
And we've never talked
about this --
-Thank you, guys.
I appreciate that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, we add
the applause in later.
We add the applause in later.
-Okay, cool.
-We do that to the monologue,
as well.
We've had you --
You've been a guest 15 times.
We've never referenced
the "You can't see me" move.
-Yeah!
-Of where -- Like, what --
Like, what is the back story?
-Okay. So, for those of you
who don't know,
get the damn Internet!
-[ Laughs ] Yeah!
Of course.
-I am -- I became a superhero
long before donning
the Peacemaker costume.
I developed a special maneuver
in the WWE,
called the "You can't see me,"
in which I put my hand
in front of my face and say,
"You can't see me."
And the reason I did this is,
because while we were making
the album
to which my theme music is on,
my younger brother, Sean,
was always our litmus test.
He kind of liked the same music,
and he would never go
to the studio with us, so we'd
come home with our tracks,
and we'd play it for him,
and he was ruthless, man.
He would never be satisfied
with any song.
And he heard, "The Time is Now"
and just did this dance
that Tony Yayo did
in of the G-Unit videos.
It was like he put his hand
over his head and just kind of,
like, bobbed his head like that.
-Oh, yeah,
I kind of remember that.
-And I was like,
"Man, what are you doing?
That looked like --
is ridiculous."
He's like, "No, no, man.
This is some Tony Yayo dancing,
doing his thing."
And I'm like,
"I'll do it on TV."
And he's like,
"I dare you to do it on TV."
[ Laughter ]
Little did he know,
I'll do this on TV, so...
[ Laughter ]
It was before then.
-Don't dare John Cena.
-So, basically -- basically,
on a dare, by absolute chance,
I went out there, and I figured
this wasn't visible enough,
so I wanted to do this.
And the term "You can't see me"
is, like, "Well, you're not
even on my level."
And then, like, years later,
it just overcame
the meme culture,
and now literally I'm invisible.
People are like,
"Why is Jimmy Fallon
talking to an empty chair?"
Like, so many people
are gonna say that.
-Yeah, they really are.
-So I'm invisible now.
-You are invisible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-On a dare!
By accident!
-I want to talk about
"Peacemaker."
Gosh, it's funny.
-Thank you.
-It is --
It's insane, as well.
-Thank you!
-Is it you or is it James Gunn
or is it a combo platter
of both?
-It's James Gunn, for sure.
He's such an unbelievably
gifted story teller,
and I think his ability
to just put together
a great squad -- pun intended.
But the mind of James Gunn is --
-He wrote all of these?
-All of these, yes.
-When does he have time
to do all this stuff?
-Well, so when we all
really got locked down,
if you saw
"The Suicide Squad" --
-Yeah.
-You know, there's a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
But Peacemaker's future
is very questionable.
And he called me up
in the middle of lockdown.
He's like, "Hey, man, I want to
do a series on Peacemaker."
I said, "Hey, man,
isn't Peacemaker dead?"
[ Laughter ]
And he was like, "No, no,
I got it taken care of."
I said, "Okay. I'm in.
No problem."
And I just let him go to work,
and he wrote eight episodes
in eight weeks,
and then we filmed
very shortly after that.
-I will just say this.
Here's where you got me.
The opening theme song.
-The big dance number.
-Dude, he's not kidding.
-Dare you to skip the intro.
[ Laughter ]
-You did something
that we've been wanting to do
is bring back the TV
kind of theme-song intro.
And you come out --
-Not quite "Too Many Cooks,"
but, I mean, it's good.
-It is like solid gold
is what I would call it.
Like the show, "Solid Gold."
[ Laughter ]
It is like you come out,
full on choreographed dancing.
Full on --
Serious face, by the way.
-Yeah. I mean, you'll all
see it, I hope, on HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You'll all see it?
-Every cast member --
Every cast member comes out
and introduces themselves,
and they're all dancing, too,
and doing these --
It's so silly, I go,
"Oh, my gosh.
He crushed it already."
Before the show even starts.
Everything's funny.
Your sidekick, your pet --
-The bald eagle -- Eagly.
[ Laughter ]
-His name is Eagly.
-Yeah, it is Eagly.
Yeah, it is Eagly.
My eagle's name is Eagly.
[ Laughter ]